welcome back to this week in startups my
guest Justin Kahn you know him founded
justin.tv twitch TV you brother crushed
it with that crews how what was that
like 18 months to a billion dollars two
years two years to a billion dollars on
my brother the remember he was telling
his team member new hires yeah like this
is going to be a billion dollar startup
in a year this was one year in he's like
this is gonna be a billion dollar
startup in a year and you want to get on
board and people joined and later on
they're like well we didn't really
believe you but you know here we go it
was amazing yeah and you were an
investor in that I was angel investor in
that and they are still you know in the
city still run you know him and Kyle are
still uh they're running by GM or Ford
GM yeah I got bought by GM they raised
knees they just raised over two billion
dollar maybe three billion dollars from
Softbank and and others and um yeah
they're they're crushing it it's crazy
it's gonna happen the self-driving thing
well I think a lot of people I have said
that they want to launch it pretty soon
in the next year or so so I think what
you're gonna start seeing some
experiments out there hopefully consumer
services I don't know I'm not really the
expert but I am eagerly anticipating for
self-driving coming out I just had
somebody on who's creating like mapping
there are all car companies so they
could all share the same sort of
visualizations deep map AI yeah I
thought it was a really good business I
wanted to invest in a business like that
but yeah so it's sort of like Google
Maps for everybody TomTom well whatever
Garmin yep but I thought was interesting
in the conversation he talked about
drawing a line in the middle of the road
so you have the two lane markers but
he's like you know if you draw a line in
the middle of the road specifically for
this like they're doing in China it so
it's really easy and I was like oh my
god we're we're spending a hundred
thousand dollars like arming a Wemo car
do this or a cruise car or whatever yeah
and literally you just paint a lot of
the money online in the middle the road
yeah and tell the car follow like a
webcam follow the line yeah and you're
done
I mean they're pretty hilarious you
could play with sensors like actual
sensors and in the cities and stuff and
make it super easy to yeah you know
we're just know we're going a hard way
can you imagine if like there was
leadership in government
take the five freeway and draw a line
from San Francisco to Los Angeles with
whatever in the line like some kind of
technology with you know every 12 inches
some marker or 10 centimeters every
truck could be self-driving today yeah
we need to we would need to be like a
different form of government I think to
make this work or it may not change form
but yes benevolent dictatorship now the
best an airship it's the best form of
government until it becomes not
benevolent exactly exactly well it's it
is interestingly when you just got back
from Hong Kong and in Hong Kong or even
Tokyo any place that's a really density
they pen the the pedestrians in yeah
don't they literally put a fence so that
cars and people are separated so on the
edge of the sidewalk there's a fence
yeah and then people don't walk in the
street and get hit by cars that would
also be a solution if we just did this
in San Francisco and Soma like things
would be so much more functional or in
New York they started to build them in
Rock Center and I think the New Yorkers
were like no we need to be able to cross
the street at any point along this
sidewalk yeah what Y Combinator class
were you and you were in the classes
that were moved here after Paul moved it
here he did a little why did this first
one in 2005 actually it's a 2005 so that
was for our first startup which is
called Kiko we didn't talk about that oh
right a web calendar there was Google
Calendar but much worse and one month
early so you've built a bad calendar a
month before Google launched their free
one yes and we also never use calendars
because we're college students at the
time so you didn't care about the
product exactly and we didn't know what
people wanted out of calendars like come
on it was that in Boston or is that when
he moved here in Boston oh you were part
of the Boston class yes with you know
Huffman from reddit Alexis yeah and
Dropbox was they were connectors later a
couple years later or two years later
who was in that first class you remember
I programs apartment yes
so Paul Graham had this apartment
doesn't do it justice cuz he had a nice
pretty cool building 135 garden Street
in in Cambridge right and he so in that
first class over eight startups there
was Sam Altman's looped right location
people forget that yes which
back by Sequoia bought by a crystal and
fire sale Green Dot sold into green
dough oh they said yeah that was like it
in portfolio landing a little soft land
I'm not saying yeah that there was a
soft landing but well they guided him in
the gate that's the guiding him in Sam
is an incredible he's incredible at
deal-making and figuring out how no I
love say oh good card player by the way
yeah and then we had read it
Steven Alexis from reddit the career to
read it now alexis is done initialized
capital he's now on to initialize
capital and Serena was mister Serena
Williams mister Serena was had that's a
full-time job yeah it seems like his
social media is of pong courses
social media has blown up sweetie
Kitty's legit celebrity now in his own
right I say he's watching good spirit
watching launch day is own Armenian
brandy I'm like how am I gonna keep up
with this kid I have a matter you need
you need your own spirit I know what am
I going what what kind of what's a Greek
that would be my guess don't Coalmont it
was oh he's not good no no it's nasty do
something Irish I'm Irish too yeah I
could do some of the Irish tip yeah
Irish but I saw that and I was like
really election okay
can we break his spirit we should we
should have some like I'll put it on the
wall next to the quick he'd queer
Queequeg quake way doll I don't know how
to pronounce it I think it's quake quake
week we any but now got his doll his
daughters got a tall his daughter's doll
has blown up on social media there's
newer Times articles about his
daughter's doll no it's our is that all
like part of a plan to release that doll
as a actual product or is that somebody
else's doll that is getting free
publicity honestly I have no idea but um
it's been hope it's the former I fear
it's the latter so crazy isn't it weird
like the internet went for being like
like an afterthought to this is a driver
of culture and all these people who or
random you know kind of oh here it is
here's quite no but you're saying yes
this random people like me and you and
well maybe not you but like Alexis and
Steve are like running the Internet
it's crazy yeah that's bonkers quake way
now has 20,000 followers not his
daughter's account his daughters all
zakat held that's like two levels
removed that's bonkers
so that first startup just fells really
quick
we spent a year on it with you basically
after why why see did a bash in the
summer of 2005 we spent a year hacking
on this calendar we launched it google
calendar came out we actually were very
distractible founder so we incubated all
these other ideas that we never properly
launched the only good thing that came
out of it was that I became a decent
programmer because we basically did this
think of it as like a year-long dev
bootcamp hmm with you know the
programming bootcamp with Paul Graham
$16,000 yeah exactly with his twelve
thousand dollars so is six thousand per
head that three founders got eighteen we
had two founders he got twelve and then
he invested personally another like
twenty thousand do you like keep his
like right I say a lot of respect for
Paul Graham you think about that that
was the bottom of the bottom and he's
like I'm going to give a bunch of kids
like you guys were babies 22 21 21 22
something like that I'm gonna give him
12 grand like he was like scraping the
back of his couch to get like whatever
he could to give you guys 12 grand
that's like real heart I thank God for
Paul Graham all the time but yeah he put
us on everybody on all these guys who
like had no like nobody would fund their
companies the companies wasn't we're an
idea we weren't even good programmers to
be honest if you think about that cohort
like think about how much value got
created just by exactly and that's the
premise of Y Combinator and YC has done
such a tremendous job in the world of
putting on all these founders right
super inspiring yeah and then you move
out here and then Justin gets accepted
to a later class or something yeah so
then just they we kind of went through
again in 2007 for like a second time and
then you went through again and then
atrium went through yeah so we have this
after we pivoted fully to twitch and we
began to see you after about a year I
started another company called exec
which is a failure oh yes I remember
exactly exact TaskRabbit meets uber I
thought that was pretty dope $25 per
hour or something that's right we should
have charged a lot more but yeah
what did you learn from that one well I
think it's really hard to make make a
service where people don't they have to
be creative to use it mm-hmm right I
think it was most people aren't that
creative I think what we should have
learned was we should have pivoted hard
to a specific thing which we end up
doing but we chose housecleaning which
is a horrible service zone right
we should have pivoted to you know
grocery delivery which is something that
people you know we'd use a postman so
we're doing that like give them a
specific use case which is classic
rabbit eventually did they were like
here pick one of these eight that's
right because you can't I love that idea
though of like a $25 an hour or Eve at
it yeah I see but I think you're right
if you had gone $50 an hour or let's say
for you and you just said forget it this
is like a one percenter thing yeah we're
gonna start like uber did just with
black cars like though it's for the 1%
or the top 5% $40 an hour but this
person is super reliable
college-educated you know and
trustworthy and vetted and you know
they're stoked to do the work because
it's a decent rate yeah I think great
really really an important thing to do
but unfortunately we we didn't do that
and I think that we didn't really pivot
to the right thing we end up selling
that coming in handy huh which just sold
an Angie's List so when you when you
rack up those kind of failures do you
how do you emotionally it was Hollins
that and deal with it because that one
is kind of high-profile right you raised
a decent minimum race like three and a
half million dollar zero which was but
it was a lot at the time yeah was a big
seed rounded it was high-profile to
high-profile you know I talked it up a
lot and and so it was hard at the second
year when I oh nothing was working I
felt horrible all the time went to
therapy yeah to try to feel you know I
felt really guilty I remember one time
we were I was really feeling and I just
broke down crying I was like sobbing to
myself well actually my co-founder was
there's a little embarrassing but you
know eventually we sold it got over it
like it was just like what have I done I
took all this money and I made all these
promises to all these employees or
whatever but what you don't realize is
look life is gonna go on your attachment
to outcome is what will cause you
suffering right because if you have an
attachment to a certain outcome and you
actually get it you're gonna create a
bigger attachment to a bigger outcome
sure if you don't get it you're gonna be
like in pain because you didn't achieve
it
and so I think that it's it creates is
unhealthy cycle where you know I spent
so many years in this unhealthy cycle
where I was like so obsessed with
getting something next you know right
and thinking that was gonna drive my
happiness and this was like kind of a
peak culmination of that you grew up
poor not really my dough class middle
class yeah my parents you know they
really emphasized education so they put
us in private schools and stuff would
you throw out Seattle oh cool yeah so it
wasn't it wasn't about like oh I need
this cuz I'm gonna I need to live I
always felt like I could get a job
somewhere or something like that so it
wasn't that fear it's more of like an
ego based attachment you know yeah
that's interesting and then you get a
couple of check boxes you get a couple
checks you get a little check boxes it
takes the edge off it does sorry I think
it does but I also think that you know
you can also create these new
attachments so you can greater outcomes
you know when you're when you're at the
beginning I remember thinking like when
we just started Kiko is like if I could
just make a million dollars who I will
be set that would be great and then you
know you achieve that we end up solar
you know Socialcam 60 mil you know so
everybody got a little money in the bank
and then the bar just keeps going up and
up and then I had friends who created
three billion five billion 10 billion 20
million dollar companies and then you're
like oh man why did I do that yeah it's
not our kind of private jet ha ha
exactly so there's there's infinite you
could always be looking up to somebody
else who was doing better than you and
it can never it will never end that's
the race to nowhere exactly and
unhappiness it's exactly it's a race to
unhappiness so I know people look at me
when I talk about like mindfulness and
kind of deleting your attachments from
your mind
people talk they're like well it's easy
for you to say because you got X you
achieve this but I'm like look I know
you're not gonna believe me but I have
experienced that although you know did
the looking up and all the way you know
is I still do I still have that yeah I
mean I I do that sometimes too because
you hang out with people when you when
you grow up in these circles like we did
yes people around you become
billionaires or other people who you
thought were the smartest kids in the
thing go broke get divorced and like
they're taking a job at Yahoo yeah and
you're like oh I think you got a yeah
just it's I have what the thing I've
learned in the most in the past couple
years is that you're
happiness is an internal thing it's not
based on external events yeah
and focusing on that has been I am I'm
like more happy today regard like X
regardless of my external circumcised it
has nothing to do my external sizes than
I ever have been in my adult life yeah
and I know why it's because you do your
gratitude Journal which we're gonna talk
back when we get back on this week in
startups
[Music]